I am perfect at it I know I'm gonna you
know what will be will be competing
right see I have everybody on my podcast
on people that me supposedly competing
but I want them to do well I think
there's enough out there for everybody I
really do I think that this is Apple's
own personal time anyway when they watch
they listen to your podcast and then a
listen to the next one
it's not like it's like it's not live
anymore nothing's live anymore that's
true I don't I don't even know when my
favorite shows come on I just put them
in the queue and then I watch him all my
shows come on on Sunday night that's how
I look at it right because that's when I
watch TV yeah that's uh that's an unique
thing and most of the [ __ ] I watched
these days is on Netflix yeah it's all
streaming yeah what a juggernaut they
are I don't think it's sustainable can't
be sustained why is that because and so
well yeah but here's the thing if I drop
60 million dollars on Netflix I drop 60
million to make a project right and you
watch it in ten hours then you're like
hey what what's next I bet you I
guarantee you in a couple years necklace
is gonna stop this the whole show comes
out in one sitting they're gonna
probably do it in chunks why would they
do that because you want you anticipate
anticipation you've wondered would it
just do your brain of the boardroom as
soon as you walked out of the come on
I'd be like fire him no man rid of him
he's [ __ ] this man have any idea
what he's talking about
nope anticipation psychologically feels
just as good as actual achieving their
thing that anticipation you feel like
waiting to see what happens that's why
you're on a Showtime show I see it burn
on this [ __ ] right here I see
what's going on you're trying to like
justify being on a Showtime show it is a
good thing it's a good thing you could
bid you at the end of the season before
engine you can still burn [ __ ] but this
model obviously is uber successful like
one of the most accessible things ever
then why are they talking about they're
losing money all the time what are you
talking about they had an article look
it up definitely some money Netflix made
their success but hundreds of millions
of subscribers I know but they put out
pay $10 a month there they make more
money than anybody but they're also
putting out money
they're given stand-up comics 20 million
dollars to make special stand-up comics
what they put out 52 specials even if
they let's say they paid a hundred
thousand which I know they didn't they
pay them way more than that for each
other that's still a lot of money right
there man yeah they make stranger things
stranger things is an expensive show a
damn good show there people watch it in
one week it's over there but then you're
saying as a Netflix person hey what's
next yeah but millions more watch it
that week no I guess people are
justifying that billion dollars a month
they spend that's why they have their
contacts constantly coming in it has to
keep Netflix is really close to surprise
surpassing Disney's valuation do you
know how crazy that is Netflix special
by the way in 2005 oh [ __ ] yeah you know
G original was oh gee son you mad you
know twenty million dollars off well I'm
happy but that that's showing you that
you're incorrect now Netflix is making
[ __ ] tons of money no no just because
they're valuable doesn't mean that
they're making a profit taking on debt
so like they're playing a it's business
so but how much do they make overs
evaluation was they took on like another
eight million err excuse me eight
billion dollars in debt so what does
that mean when I do that but is it based
on their earnings like cuz they if well
aren't they making billions of dollars a
year and they're making money and then
they took on more debts there's two
reinvested it back into the company I'm
not really interested in turning a
profit may be for 2017 they're looking
more in tech 2025 that's what I'm
talking about you do you know what
you're saying
did you guess it's not sustainable but
how much do they make let's find out
instead of just guessing nothing to give
a [ __ ] but obviously Eric does because
he's so invested in Showtime this guy's
model of what is Showtime do to you see
that time I saw you
a Netflix special that I've did in 2005
we actually sold the Showtime
see I got the rights to it and how you
going back to Netflix get one of them
licensing deals well now I my life
some dealers just gonna I don't know
what its gonna be I don't know my first
special I did with rooftop which was now
owned by Amazon so I think you can get
the audience good you can get the audio
on I think Amazon's gonna buy Netflix
watch what Showtime has done for [ __ ]
Sebastian so I'm saying it I mean it's
not a bad place I mean if Showtime wants
to be in the Eric Griffin business I'm
all about it yeah no I hear you man